feel free to not call me a good Che as
well come on 30 episodes
[Music]
in right welcome to scrambled where I'm
cooking my favorite breakfast dish you
know that is scrambled eggs and today
I'm cooking with a quadrupled threat cuz
not only is she an actress a singer a
producer and rumor has it a toned Chef
please welcome the amazing slena
Gomez thanks for having me right you
ready yes um season three four three
three go back to the beginning no I'm
four but but how good have you become
the SK um I've been decent I would say
I've gotten a little better but I'm
nowhere near your status sh I hope not
I'll be out of the job um breakfast
what's your favorite thing to eat in
breakfast it depends I like a nice you
know breakfast sandwich or a little like
taco bur um I remember being on my ass
at the age of 22 in the middle of Paris
and I learned to make the most amazing
scrambled egg really so I'm going to
elevate this thing into a sort of
scrambled egg turkey beautiful bun okay
and it's like a breakfast but sometimes
I have it for lunch as well all right
how do you make your scrambled eggs
please don't mention
Mike no no good no not at all no cuz
last time I asked somebody that they
said I sticking the microwave for 2
minutes no you can do that no no please
don't don't do that don't do that okay
how'd you make your scrumbled eggs well
add a little butter and kind of just
spin it around sometimes I add milk
but
okay no milk okay you're going to do the
eggs okay so um always crack the eggs on
a flat surface okay okay everyone goes
on the corner which then puts the shell
inside so flat and open up and in there
you go good so let's start off with uh
let's go six eggs okay please and we're
not going to season them either okay yep
I tell you why because it turns the eggs
gray and there's nothing worse than gray
scrambled eggs right e that's so gross
so um I finish work sometimes 9 10:00 at
night and this is the perfect what
happened I got a little in
sh um did you just say oh sorry sh
please we're live no
swe uh go-to favorite uh snack on the
road what would it be uh probably a
chicken salad chicken salad yes and
working those crazy hours right yes um
what don't you like eating uh I
definitely have a hard time with
greens yeah I need to be better with
that yeah what about you uh do you know
Chef don't really get chance to eat
properly cuz we graze no and so what we
do is like sort of eat five times a day
but small bits and any chef would be
lying saying that we eat dinner before
we cook dinner cuz that's just BS no
okay you know you have to stay Nimble
right and so you have to taste and you
have to perfect and so if you go into it
not hungry your food becomes lazy
interesting so we never eat before we
cook I'm always hungry when I cook uh
that's for you thank you uh right uh
eggs in there so now um about four nice
little knobs of butter okay and to stop
the eggs from overcooking mhm we're
going to throw in a little touch of
creme fresh really so it just gives that
it gives it a little bit of tartness but
more importantly it's sort of it stops
it from becoming too creamy so if you
can't get creme fresh it's sour cream
very similar but just a little touch
richer um I love sour two more little
knobs of butter oh okay okay and then
we're going to go on the stove now we're
going to bring up the heat okay and then
we're going to come on and off so come
over please yes now onto the stove okay
there we go now we'll just get that
stirring there and so what we're doing
now is give that a little stir okay and
as it starts to cook we're going to come
back off the heat and I'll explain why
in a minute okay so so give that a
little stir got it buns nicely toasted
that way they don't get soggy and no one
toast the top part as well I don't know
why but it's a bit of a sort of a chef
thing when we toast both sides of the
bun that means we can layer it up and
stack it okay yes I do not like when
scrambled eggs are burned no nothing
worse they're going to go on and they
can just cool down nicely on top um it's
a nice light Brios bun okay okay so
there we go um I suppose after any gig
um you're too hyped to sit down and eat
properly because the excitement is
constant right my adrenaline is through
the roof and so what's the what's the
go-to naughty snack what's the one thing
that you sort of sometimes Jack in the
Box do you even know what that
is I get two tacos two egg rolls curly
fries and a chicken sand do you know
what mine is what that in and out in and
out in and out I let's see that
drive-thru it's it's pretty great
honestly once I went in there and I was
so freaking hungry I actually ran round
and drove around and came around twice
can you believe that I know I know I
know I know so I do that when I'm drug
there you go now turkey bacon in same
pan now let me show you a little trick
with here now so you can leave that in
oh yeah unlock so the secret here is you
clean that pan and it's a stick pan okay
so all you do is just wipe that back
Round And as they start thickening up
this is where we take it off now and it
continues cooking because the heat in
the pan is going to literally continue
cooking sew round so I always go sort of
1 minute on 30 seconds off okay wow so
I'm back on the serve again now good
that's so neat um favorite country after
touring acting where would you say one
of the most beautiful countries you
visited oh old man uh you know I
actually love Oslo Oslo randomly I had
one of the most amazing nights and the
crowd is incredible uh obviously I love
the UK y but but that's like a given I
think yeah I mean do you not find the UK
wildo in terms of the the amount of
support you got there yes which is
incredible when we're cooking a turkey
sort of Pate stroke Burger it needs
color and everyone gets a little bit
nervous about putting color on there so
I start with a little bit of O and then
finish with butter do I take this off
and back off again now and then we
scrape around again there you go and I
quite like it when it's nice and Big And
Chunky like that so it doesn't go too
bitty got it so now it's coming together
love see how vibrant that color is so
clean all the way down and continue
scraping and now I'm going to bring over
the salt and pepper okay okay so give
them a little season mhm
now there's something quite unique about
Oslo though isn't there in a way that
everything's just so clean there yeah do
you not
think it's so
beautiful so beautiful it really is
what's your one of your favorite places
uh Paris I lived there for 3 years so
one of the most romantic cities anywhere
in the world that from a chef's point of
view I've got a
dialogue tablespoon of Crum fresh wow
whip that in and then from there
I want you to come and just slice these
chives I'll show you why so Bunch them
up yeah that's nice good and then take
that over to your over to your
bench that can sit there and literally
rest right so
fun so you can see how fluffy that is
now can't you it's so it looks delicious
and that
beautiful creme fresh at the end just
stops that from becoming a little bit
too rich amazing now from there Bunch up
those chives y okay and then
just hold the knife and let the knife do
the work and just slice down all the way
through watch the fingers one in front
two behind this knuckle protects them
remember what I showed you last time
round yes don't screw this up okay
please you need those fingers pressure
thanks you need those Fingers um Chef's
over the last three or four years have
done lots of collaborations in terms of
exciting popups yes uh from an artist
point of view what's been your favorite
collaboration cuz you've done so many
beautiful collabs oh you know that's one
of the best parts I have to say working
with Coldplay was a huge bucket list
moment and I've been a fan of obviously
Chris's for so long exactly and they're
lovely so that was really great yeah and
then in terms of
the one you did with Charlie proof yeah
we don't how cool how cool was that
that's fun right give that little mix in
y and then again we don't put it in the
bun and then all of a sudden start
seasoning we sort of season everything
now that doesn't make sense see that's
lovely
nice good yeah it's lovely delicious a
little touch of fresh pepper
okay so this is a delicious scramble day
everyone thinks scramble day can only be
eaten for breakfast which is absolute
rubbish in Paris I had scrambled eggs
for breakfast lunch and dinner for
dinner would go for beautiful wild
mushrooms sauteed with scrambled eggs oh
I love mushrooms and then for lunch a
little bit of oie seaing I'm looking at
that out there seeing inside that
scrumbled egg now we just lift that
thing to Oblivion really on a different
level so cool different level so we're
going to layer okay that's beautifully
done there's your base and there's mine
now I always think about the buildout
okay how do we build this thing yes how
do we create excitement the first thing
we're going to do is get a little touch
of chipotle mayonnaise chipotle
mayonnaise is that that's it okay and
just literally there that's going to
give a little bit of heat on there okay
yep now from there take your avocado
okay okay and then just literally was
your fingers all the way
through okay and then you just twist it
just releases the stone and then very
carefully get your knife and just
crisscross don't go all the way through
okay just one way turn it
around through and just be very very
careful the point of that knife all
right I'm not going to have this up just
nice and carefully okay I'll explain why
the
crisscrossing from there a little touch
of lime
inside yum a nice little seat season and
all you've done then is you've literally
just cut up and chopped up your avocado
so it comes out you sit that on the
bottom so we don't need to take it and
crush it you've chopped it up and look
it's a really nice way of been getting
chopped avocado on your breakfast bun so
freaking good now from there I feel like
I'm not doing a bad job that's good A
little season of lime that stops IT from
discoloring okay good
there you go and then you scrape out
with your spoon onto the base you can
see why I toasted the Buns to begin with
yeah and now from there I take my bib
lettuce and I just go over that
now and then from there push that
down good great great little bit of
lettuce on Top push that
down now my turkey there's yours thank
you you can see where I'm going now cuz
it's like this amazing Meal please tell
me there's cheese involved there is
right at the very end okay oh that looks
so good just let that Cascade down
nothing wrong with that now take that
lovely layer of cheddar cheese on top oh
right here that's it on top and then
finally one more little spoon of that
beautiful
mayonnaise okay good
on and then
that on there a little touch of rocket
for some pepper and now through and then
from
there stick goes in sh okay push that
down now I like everything oozing out oh
it looks so good and then just from
there I go down I let the knife do the
work
wow another stick in that side and
look the most beautiful wow beautiful
breakfast bun one there one there slice
down the middle and have a look at that
magic oh my gosh this is so freaking
cool oh wait that's it saw sorry saw
like I showed you last time with the
fish girl how could you forget that so
quickly I did and there we go the most
amazing delicious breakfast bun looks so
good oh
yeah oh
holy this is so good M it's
chipotle
mayonnaise girl sorry ever thought about
getting your own TV series this is so
good so freaking easy I know you can do
that right mhm yeah promise you that's
your go-to SC I promise you I'm going to
make this tomorrow morning light fluffy
mhm delicious well done thanks so much
for watching scrambled and don't forget
to catch Selena and Chef with yours
truly on HBO Max and don't forget to
leave a comment on Whose breakfast
Burger you prefer girl you're getting
good me and mine might be good good job
I would I could legit make this I think
good job awesome really good job Legend
F we forgot the turkey bacon uh in in
London